they're interested
hey
I'm sad now okay so what what's going on
y'all are separated or what what's the
deal we have
okay we're living in the same house
Hell On Earth as you can imagine okay
um
but anyway woke up this morning we have
travel plans to leave
and he's insisting that I don't go
okay
and then I have my keys he starts moves
me out of the way starts trying to
unload my car tells me he owns the car
he owns the rights to it
just got super aggressive and that's
when I called immediately because he's
been physical before and I'm just not
okay
not doing that so are you just wanting
to leave
or is he supposed to be going with you
yeah we're supposed to be going with our
kids
okay
all right
um
no what that's what I was asking
dispatch like what y'all can do if
there's even
but of course now he's inside action
I mean I don't know what it is that you
want us to do I mean if y'all have filed
for divorce and y'all are going on a
vacation other than telling him he needs
to calm down
I don't personally recommend you go on a
vacation if together if I was better
than Thursday if there's an issue like
that and y'all have filed for divorce I
mean it's obviously a hostile situation
right so is there a way that you can go
without him or
yeah
I mean the best thing what we're going
to do is tell you all that y'all need to
separate
has he put his hands on you that you
know have you all been physically
aggressive today I mean no just besides
him moving me out of the way of my car
to get to it
okay what do you mean he moved you out
of the way he's like pushed me out of
the way so he could get to my car and
start unloading it
we're gonna need to talk to him then
huh
until he comes out here and decides to
show out so I don't know what's going to
happen with that
nope
somebody was
almost
this house
before they realized it
what in the hell
why are you filed for divorce I'm gonna
go on vacation together
and that's not something that we can
work out for you I mean because we're
going to tell you to separate
[Music]
okay so so what's going on this morning
she's had her couple's Trip playing with
her boyfriend into Key West okay but she
just said you're going
to our kids
yesterday she sent the message saying
that she's going to change her plans and
now get on the airplane with me and the
kids to go to the Bahamas
she's going
she's a boyfriend elsewhere and me and
the kids are going to our house
I'm not supporting that
and you're not getting on the airplane
that can mess with the kids heads and
it's just something we're not going to
do well
150 of an airplane
see you on paper on this 25 of that
and majority owner the owner or the
other 50 other
and myself are both in agreeance to not
have on the internet
so 75 percent as
that doesn't mean you get aggressive
push me out of the way start unloading
my car this year
yes at the back of the car
he doesn't want me to go I raise the
back to grab my kids soup
with a locked car
I'm gonna
tell you both like I told you a minute
ago
y'all are filed for divorce okay
in situations like this the best thing
that we always recommend is y'all
separate don't just separate from each
other
you don't need to be going on vacation
together if you file for divorce and
it's obviously a volatile situation
that I mean I don't I don't know how
else to to put it other than that okay
um as far as the pushing and shoving say
Georgia advises that you put your hands
on each other that is an act of simple
assault and you can be arrested on that
for Family Violence okay
um you're saying he did he's saying he
didn't so I got if you want I can't I
can't I can't sit here it's a he said
she said situation we run into it all
the time so what's gonna all
done okay so here's what's gonna happen
today I'm gonna generate a report that
we were out here and that we made
contact with the both of you I'm gonna
generate a report that states you said
he physically moved you away from the
vehicle by pushing you away from the
vehicle you say I didn't do that I
opened the back hatch of the vehicle got
suitcases out
in front saying you're not grabbing them
and move me out of the way exactly
that we're not going to go back and
forth that's how we're gonna do that my
next
I mean I can't tell her she can't go on
vacation with you okay it's marital
property that's that already said okay
it's all gonna all be that's all gonna
be civil civil issues I I can't stop her
I can't say you can't go wherever the
heck it is you want to go I can't tell
you you can that that has nothing to do
with what we're doing here we're here
because of acts of violence to calm the
situation that's what we're here to do
okay I can't
I can't control y'all going on vacation
I don't recommend going on vacation
together but that's just my personal
reasons
do you have any identification okay can
I get that please do you have your ID on
you
Mr Shriver what's your phone number two
two one what was it seven five five
seven nine
now since since I owned this vehicle and
it's solely in my name it's marital
property right now she still has access
to it okay I understand she has access
to it but can I get my kids suitcases
out of the back yeah
you can get your children's property out
of it so he can get the kids stuff out
of my car it's marital property
and I don't have any paperwork saying
that he's not allowed access to the
children's property he's just not able
to move me out of the way to get it
right
he said she said
pilot already said Lindsay that it's too
late
he has to pick up the other owner
after he drops us so we can't be late
here's your honey back
about what time this morning did all
this start 7 A.M
so you're supposed to be going to the
Key West in Kansas City
together
well aware I text the pilot
everybody knew it
okay
he's just being extremely difficult
that's nothing Perkin name okay so are
you leaving now
okay all right there's two that are
places okay all right
um like I said my only recommendation
for you is that y'all just separated
it's always just gonna be a cheesecake
I mean you get video footage you have
surveillance cameras you have something
that I can look at and say yes he put
his hands on you
I mean you know we have an independent
witness that's non-biased I mean you
know something
other statements but right now I have
you and him
and you know he's saying one thing
you're saying another you know
I mean if it's this type of situation
y'all just need to separate I mean just
don't don't be around each other if it's
going to be like this how do we do that
when three kids
all right what do you have cops
I'm able to get my kids stuff back out
of the vehicle okay why are we doing
this though why why do you need to do
that
well because he's taking my kids so
we're going to go back and so we're
going to stand here while y'all go back
and forth moving suitcases back and
forth between cars
if that's what you feel like you need to
do then then I mean then by all means do
it but you understand it it's making the
situation worse
and you're doing it in front of the
children now
I don't our plans have been
picked up
Lennon just called me
well I'll go get directions
you've heard me say the pilot said it's
too late
where is she going
because I need to get them
we're just not
I'm trying to take all three bullets
which is what I've had plans
for example
where is he right now
whose house is he on
you can pick them up on the way down
so you're free to go
yeah
okay wait right here I gotta get you
both Pace number okay
summertime
foreign
ers
Mr case number
2023-27264 there's information here if
you need anything else okay appreciate
it thank you
I mean I gotta document both sides
it is what it is
um
I'm going to generate a miscellaneous
Family Violence report this is your case
number is
2023-27264. if you have any questions
you can talk to the Justice Center and
speak to an officer
um
all right all right thank you yes ma'am
yes sir y'all have a better day
money
hmm
foreign